jetzt müssen wir darüber sprechen
steuergeld einfach im klo versenkt
genauer gesagt in diesem schulklo dass
wir ihnen jetzt zeigen und das in zeiten
in denen angeblich alle überall ganz
dringend sparen müssen man was für eine
irre geschichte da aus essen die stadt
hat insgesamt
147 schultoiletten sanieren lassen das
ja erstmal eine gute geschichte weil die
völlig hinüber waren das werden sie von
ihren kindern wahrscheinlich auch kennen
so weit so gut also aber wie so oft die
kosten sind dann völlig völlig aus dem
ruder gelaufen aber sowas von was
glauben sie was so eine toilette dann am
ende gekostet hat nicht 5000 euro nicht
10.000 euro eine toilette für
346.000 eur 51 millionen euro insgesamt
wird los die teuersten schultoiletten
deutschland sie gibt es ab jetzt in
essen und da ist unser bild reporter
michael engelberg vor den teuersten
toiletten in denen so viel steuergeld
versenkt wurde man wie kann das sein
michael
jamaika ja wir gehen mal eben einmal ein
bisschen zur seite es hat ja gerade die
pause begonnen wir müssen uns ein
bisschen beeilen ja wir sehen das
gebäude und wir sehen die schule und wir
sehen auch alle und können einfach
nachvollziehen wie es riecht wenn man
auf schultoiletten ist es ist nicht
immer eine wahre freude viele kinder
haben angst auf die toilette zu gehen
weil es einfach total marode ist und
warum die kosten so in die höhe
geschlagen sind es nämlich keine wc ente
kann und silke lenz erzählen das ist die
sprecherin der stadt essen vollends
kohle versenkt oder gut angelegt die
kohle ist für die schülerinnen und
schüler und vor allem für die schulen
auf jeden fall gut angelegt und wir
verbauen hier auch keine goldenen henne
sondern wir sanieren toiletten die seit
vielen jahrzehnten ehrlicherweise nicht
saniert worden sind das ganze programm
ist 2017 aufgelegt worden und zwischen
2017 und 2022 ist eine menge passiert
corona ist passiert beispielsweise der
ukraine krieg ist passiert wir haben die
standorte genau untersucht und habe
neben festgestellt das was auf dem blatt
papier steht nicht das ist was wir
vorfinden nämlich sehr oft eine marode
substanz
wenn ich aber eine ausschreibung machen
ist normalerweise eine preis festgelegt
was hätte es denn vorher kosten sollen
und
ist es da nicht so wenn ich was ja quasi
in auftrag gebe dass ich das dann auch
quasi so bezahle wie es ist also alle
dinge die wir in die hand nehmen müssen
ausgeschrieben werden insofern sind wir
natürlich daran gehalten erst mal eben
das bestmögliche angebot anzunehmen das
tun wir auch und insofern haben wir
natürlich auch preise im vorfeld durch
ausschreibungen ermittelt aber ich habe
gerade angesprochen die korona krise
jetzt im moment der ukraine krieg also
dritt kosten nämlich für baumaterialien
oder steigende kosten weil man auf
andere substanzen also marode substanzen
gestoßen ist und einfach mehr arbeiten
anfallen das kann man nicht weitergeben
an denjenigen der den auftrag angenommen
hat sondern da muss man eben tatsächlich
die dritt kosten eben auch übernehmen
und insofern kommt es jetzt dazu dass
die kosten für die toiletten und es sind
147 anlagen die wir sanieren sich leider
erhöhen was hätte es denn ursprünglich
kosten soll wir haben mal angefangen
weil 25 millionen euro damit sind wir
sozusagen gestartet in die planung dann
hat man sich die 147 anlagen die wir
jetzt sanieren genauer angeschaut und
hat kategorien gebildet kategorie 1 2
und 3 das heißt also da wo es besonders
dringlich ist oder auch wo der bedarf
besonders hoch ist wir sprechen hier von
komplettsanierung von teilsanierung oder
eben auch instandsetzungen im bestand
und schon eben bei den ersten planungen
hat sich gezeigt dass wir es eben mit
situation zu tun haben die auf dem
papier so nicht erkennbar waren und dass
die kosten eben schon damals gestiegen
sind jetzt bei rund 150 millionen euro
und wir hoffen dass der zenit
überschritten ist was das thema
baukostensteigerungen angeht und das
wäre dann eben auch wieder in eine
entspanntere lage kommen herzlichen dank
wie gesagt es ist keine wc ente und ja
auch greenstein kann man nicht bauen da
muss man tatsächlich alles abreißen und
neu bauen ist soll nachhaltig sein jeder
kennen das mit edding dran geschrieben
willst du mit mir gehen ja nein
vielleicht das muss alles irgendwie auch
abwaschbar sein das muss alles
nachhaltig sein das muss alles auch
unzerstörbar seien vandalismus auf
schultoiletten ist jetzt auch ein großes
thema wir werden die sache ja weiterhin
verfolgen mit diesen eindrücken von der
realschule zollverein aus dem schönen
essen zurück nach berlin er vor allen
dingen wenn wir das nicht aber so
hinnehmen dass so eine toilette 346.000
euro halt kostet das ging bei uns zu
hause ja auch irgendwie ein bisschen
danke an unseren bild reporter michael
engelberg also ihre geschichte weiterhin
patricia der wird so teuer dieses klo
oder saniert diese toilettenanlagen erst
mal toll dass ich endlich jemand darum
kümmern aber das ist so was denn so
krass aus dem ruder läuft
sagt dana ist halt so ist jetzt halt
mehr als doppelt so teuer geworden ihre
geschichte darüber müssen wir weiter
sprechen das sind steuergelder wir sind
jetzt mit jetzt ammann verbunden vom
bund der steuerzahler in nordrhein
westfalen schönen guten tag gehen wir
uns gerade gesagt es ist eine gute
nachricht endlich mit war es getan für
schultoiletten der preis für eine
toilette hat uns aber dann doch ein
bisschen erstaunt wie finden sie das wie
ist es überhaupt möglich so was auf
kosten der steuerzahler ist muss noch
billiger gehen ja morgen erst einmal das
ist natürlich richtig zu messen müssen
immer grundsätzlich die kriterien der
sparsamkeit und der wirtschaftlichkeit
angewendet
auf der anderen seite konnten die
richter nicht nachvollziehen warum es
nur einer solchen preissteigerung
gekommen ist ob die preise wirklich
gerechtfertigt sind für
anlagen kann man glaube ich draußen
stehen also gar nicht wirklich
beurteilen
das ist die maßnahmen müssten wir diesem
ziel hat richtig aber ob sich so toll
werden musste das ist nicht die frage
das heißt wir trauen uns gemeinsam nicht
zu zu beurteilen ob über 300.000 euro
für eine toilette im schnitt ob das zu
viel oder zu wenig ist das trauen wir
uns nicht an bewertungen zu es ist ja so
ist halt eine einzelne toilette die es
gemacht worden ist es in der ganzen
anlage ist natürlich auch bedenken
toiletten an dass möglicherweise auch im
obergeschoss und es muss man
möglicherweise müssen sämtliche
leitungen bis nach um
hingelegt werden also auch ein dritter
preis ist durch nichts gerechtfertigt
ist wenn nicht können wir glaube ich als
außenstehende so nichts sagen was wir
sagen können ist dass offensichtlich
allerdings im vorfeld nicht ordentlich
geplant worden ist wenn eine
verdoppelung der preise damit zu
rechtfertigen dass wir jetzt einen
ukraine krieg kam das khroma gewesen ist
müsst ihr es eine preissteigerung arm
das hatte ich wiederum für sehr gewagt
ich gehe davon aus dass im vorfeld nicht
ordentlich ermittelt worden ist was denn
überhaupt gemacht werden muss und dass
der wahre skandal
das klingt danach die kosten dann
anschließend doppelt so hoch sind wie
geplant also steuergeld verschleudert er
da gut angelegt ganz kurz also von
verschwendung konnte ich kann ich hier
bestimmt nicht sprechen sämtliche
steuergelder jetzt hier auch sparsam und
wirtschaftlich angelegt worden sind
können wir natürlich an zuschauern auch
gar nicht zu beurteilen ich würde sagen
im vorfeld man hätte man besser planen
müssen den profi hätte man klar die
kosten gemessen müssen was man denn
überhaupt die maßnahmen beginnt also
schultoiletten so teuer wie in
reihenhaus danke an den steuerzahlerbund
in nordrhein westfalen also hier wurde
steuergeld ganz offenbar im klo versenkt
wenn die kosten so drastisch steigen
dagegen
[Musik]